why do you feel like
um the shroom games going because it
feels like at least on the black market
it's the new packs it's the new it's the
new way to get margins it's the new way
to make some [__] serious money it's
obviously a extremely illegal to
psilocybin but in certain places like
Oakland I think San Francisco now legal
or decriminalized I know oh yeah they
don't give a [__] about that [__] I
think shrooms is about to be a big wave
I think it's going to be just like the
Cannabis it seems like the next thing
that's about to get poured out quickly
get morning quickly
um you know there's obviously
um High medicinal purposes for it
especially therapeutic space 100 like
even without psilocybin mushrooms are
good for your body they're good for your
for your for your minds because you have
um caps you have caps which is uh legal
mushrooms that you could go buy at any I
mean I'm assuming any cookies dispenser
Yeah we actually got like a some kind of
like um
so kind of like not a war but like some
kind of like some kind of acknowledgment
in men's health about cash but I planted
that seed real early caps right because
whenever psilocida comes to be a thing
you already have caps I already have
caps and you know
[__] it I'll tell you and whatever but
like we already have a bunch of
different like r d going on with like
real you know psilocybin style mushrooms
and like just finding the best you know
the best type of mushroom and you know
just kind of like doing our research on
a very small level in the background so
when that time comes we cheat just like
genetics like yeah it's nothing it's
nothing different because there's penis
envy there's tidal waves there's I mean
there's all different strains that do
different things that hit you
differently that'll give you different
emotional you know reactions and yeah
visibilities and so you know we're just
we're we're slow playing that we got the
legal side of mushrooms already on deck
and they're really good for your sleep
and really good for your daytime you
know I love them man yeah they're good
for you know for like the mind and being
a sharp and when you know recreational
hits for psilocybin weren't positioned
to introduce it be ready and in a very
good way with like purpose and like with
good quality product but I think that
psilocybin would just be just like the
canvas industry all these chats are
going to come in try to [__] it up I
think that's actually
happening right now because I I saw I
just watched a YouTube video
um that someone's trying to trademark or
copyright like psilocybin therapy which
is a weird thing to try to
like it's it's some weirdo [__] going on
already in that space yeah [__] all that
[__] I'm crazy like in your position
right being in so many different cities
so many different markets do you ever
have to deal with like any because you
know I know right now there are
lobbyists that are trying to get suicide
and [__] pass through but do you ever
have to deal with like politicians or
anybody who's like because that's it
feels like it feels like there's
definitely got to be a agenda or Lobby
on both sides to make it federally legal
and or illegal and it feels like you
might have some sort of insight on what
they're like on like in certain markets
like when they're holding back our
license to open in a store I'll talk to
like certain uh politicians and kind of
just say hey like what's going on like
we'd love to build you know whooping a
good chance to say hello but I I mean
bro if I remember right at the White
House or if I'm ever invited somewhere
around some of these lawmakers I would
love to give my input I was gonna say do
you think federally it's gonna happen
soon in terms of no no time here 10
years I feel like I don't know why one
of these [__] [__] running for
president doesn't just [__] say guys
I'm gonna make weed leaves because
there's too many old people in position
presidents are just puppets it's just
[__] crazy yeah you would think like
you you probably win the election just
run that you're making weed legal and
you're gonna free [__] marijuana
prisoners that's crazy they don't want
to do that there's too much money behind
keeping people locked up and there's so
many old people with old thoughts and
old agendas in position we need some of
these guys to kind of phase out and let
the new generation take office I give it
10 years I think 10 years I would love
to be optimistic and say if we can go
legal soon so I can really build my
business the way it should be built and
we can give her these weird ass laws
like 280 and [__] but I don't see it
happening anytime soon that's why I
spread my wings really hard and stay
relevant many other ways